but not a straight line Adam Lambert
dishing on his road to love and teasing
new music what do you want fans to know
about this next era of Adam Lambert oh
you know I don't know if I can say too
much because the music's not out yet but
it's um it's definitely something a
little different sounding than what I've
done in the past I think I'm I'm really
proud of it I feel like this this music
is sort of my strongest yet I love that
you said you also took the time to get
yourself right before you worked on this
new stuff like a year or two ago I was
more like two and a half years ago and I
I was just not inspired I couldn't find
it and so through the support of friends
and family and some you know you know
soul-searching it started kind of
rebuilding from the ground up about what
was important to me as an artist what
inspired me and why I do this in the
first place the real reason and to me
making music and performing for people
is at the heart of it so I had to tap
back into that and get my head out of
the business we are now you're working
up right we're gonna this next album you
have a new man in your life oh yeah how
much it has your boyfriend kind of
influenced your music and your life now
well we've only been together a short
while so I had definitely been working
on this album well before that but it's
definitely like it's kind of a sweet
finale to the whole process and the
whole journey you know I I think the
album when people hear it they'll really
like the fact that it kind of goes
through the steps that it takes to look
for happiness and to look for
contentment et caught up with a singer
at the GLAAD Media Awards in Beverly
Hills Thursday where's it mean to be
here tonight
I love the GLAAD Awards I received a
GLAAD award a couple years ago and
I love coming to eat and Adam couldn't
help but gush over Beyonce I don't know
that you had a GLAAD award before
Beyonce did she is in the room so
excited
who accepted the Vanguard Award with her
hubby jay-z was super grateful and
honored thank y'all beyonce advocates
for women at a fierce level i think she
advocates for anybody that's
disenfranchised I think that her
commentary through her art is
breathtaking
[Music]